tonight once again the Democratic Party
the media mob they want to impeach your
duly elected president of the United
States over what is a big huge pile of
nothing this is even a thousand and one
times weaker than the Russia witch-hunt
the Ukrainian witch-hunt after days and
days and days non-stop psychotic
hysteria about a phone call between
President Trump the president of Ukraine
called it nobody knew the contents of
even without knowing the contents the
raging Democrats they announced
impeachment anyway with no knowledge
well just stop and think about this for
a second
now clearly they weren't going to make
the mistake of allowing a special
counsel like Muller to decide again and
disappoint them again after three years
now after the impeachment announcement
the transcript has in fact been released
this is after they said they would
impeach him over what they didn't know
was in it no quid pro quo no discussion
of US aid no misconduct at all
whatsoever zero zip nada nothing and
according to reports the so-called
whistleblower is a partisan hack whose
claims are politically motivated total
BS who is actually represented by a law
firm they put up like billboards and
they pay officials who leak dirt illegal
in some cases against Donald Trump or as
The Wall Street Journal's Kimberly
Strasse will put it another internal
attempt to take out a president on the
basis of another non smoking gun this is
where it gets serious we have in this
country now deep state operatives
they're alive and well and here is how
bad things have gotten in this country
today because of this anti Trump rage
psychosis the President of the United
States can't make a phone call to a
foreign leader without getting spied on
and stabbed in the back by unelected
bureaucrats people weaponizing the
powerful tools of intelligence and
turning it on the American people and
their president you think about this our
presidents trying to lead a government
and he has people within his own
government that are actively working
against him every
des the only favor president Trump
requested from his Ukrainian counterpart
during that call was an inquiry into
election hacking from 2016
I thought the mob and Democrats cared
about that and by the way the Ukrainian
president he brought up Rudy Giuliani in
the course of the conversation and as
for the brief conversation about Joel
303 300 but the president was right
the president had promised this country
to drain the swamp he has a
constitutional duty a sworn duty to find
out if the former vice president of this
country
abused his office your tax dollars to
protect his own son from possible
indictment and financial gain and
noticed that the same people same crowd
that were wrong with their conspiracies
and lies and their hoaxes for nearly
three years raging against the president
they're never gonna say a word about
Biden yeah we have him on tape
leveraging your taxpayer money to fire
the prosecutor that he knows his
investigating his son for corruption
because the New York Times and others
gave him a heads-up not a peep
I ought to be honest I'm very honest
tonight as I always am I worry about the
future of this country in this Republic
it's a republic if you can keep it pen
Franklin said I'm beginning to wonder if
we can keep it under these conditions
you read that transcript that they
released President didn't have to
release it you're going to find the
Ukrainian president he's already
familiar with Biden and his son and the
prosecutor that was fired for no reason
except to get rid of the investigation
into his son and he already by the way
planned to investigate with a new
Attorney General equivalent in their
country but as of yet to be clear
according to the DOJ President Trump has
not asked our Attorney General bar to
investigate Biden the president never
once mentioned it to our Attorney
General bar nor did the AG ever contact
the country of Ukraine and as the
president of Ukraine emphasized today
President Trump did nothing wrong he
gets it
too bad the mob and the Democratic Party
that is obsessed with they can't beat
him at the ballot box watch we had I
think good
call it was normal we spoke about many
things and I so I think and you are
ready that nobody push it push me yes
nobody zero misconduct here from
president Trump zero conflicts of
interest zero abuse of power that
doesn't matter in this environment of
rage and hatred and really a power gret
they want their power back so bad and
that's the Democrats and that's your
media the mob they're blinded by hate
now they're crippling the ability of a
President of the United States to
fulfill his enumerated power remember
he's the commander-in-chief what foreign
leader is ever going to want to talk
freely to our president knowing he's
being spied on that means they're being
spied on and also the President does
have a sworn duty to faithfully execute
the laws of the United States that's
getting to the truth Joe Biden is on
tape bragging about law breaking that
doesn't seem to concern anyone that
hates Trump instead they have publicly
called for Trump's impeachment House
even before they knew what was in it
they've been doing this since 2017 the
first month the president's in office
and Pelosi announcement yesterday about
an official impeachment inquiry it means
nothing it was a nothing that's what
they've been doing the whole time anyway
they've been conducting a never-ending
impeachment inquiry since President
Trump and Melania Trump came down the
escalator in Trump Tower and tower and
2015 what we're seeing playing out over
the course of three years is now a party
that has put pay attention to this their
rage their hatred whether they know it
or not they're now putting their hatred
ahead of President Trump but more
importantly above all else above what is
in the best interest of this country and
that would be for a president to be able
to freely conduct foreign policy as
commander-in-chief and today President
Trump called them out for what is their
disgusting just destructive petulant
malicious never-ending behavior good for
him take a look
what these Democrats have done to ruin
lives is so sad I have seen people with
only good intention they came to
Washington because they
to make the United States and the world
a better place and they went home they
were dark when you see what happened
with the viciousness and when you see
little Adam Schiff go out and lie and
lie and stand it than my smart guy by
the way stand at the mic and act like
he's so serious and then he goes into a
room with Nadler and they must laugh
their asses off
they must laugh their asses off but it's
so bad for our country bad for our
country the president's right oh you
know get the billion dollars
I'm leaving in six hours you the fire
that prosecutor you're not getting the
billion dollars you're not gonna get it
the guy that's investigating my son and
son of a B they fired him it's all on
tape Democrats their fake their phony
impeachment hysteria this now has
serious significant consequences for the
future of this country if you pay an
attention we've seen the contents of the
phone calls leak between Trump of Mexico
and President Trump in Australia now
President Trump in Ukraine and yet to
date no one is even asking how the
so-called whistleblowers claims were
leaked no one the political agenda how
did they get this information on a
President of the United States
repeatedly with no consequences and now
no president in the future is ever going
to be able to have a candid honest
conversation with another world leader
on the phone that makes us less safe in
the end doesn't it now the trust has
forever been ruined it's beyond a
terrible precedent this has national
security implications for our kids and
grandkids you don't care about yourself
the Democrats it's their political game
look at all the hypocrisy surrounding
this one very issue Democrats they claim
the Trump should be impeached over some
kind of non existing quid pro quo and
there was no quid and no pro and no quo
election collusion with Ukraine it's
like four separate investigations no
Trump Russia collusion in reality the
DNC the mob their friends the extension
of their press office they have been
colluding themselves with Ukraine since
we've reported it and Joe Biden has now
opened the door to reexamine at all
remember John Solomon right here on this
program March 2016 a contractor for the
Democratic National Committee was
pressing the Ukrainian embassy why
because the DNC operative wanted to find
Russian dirt on Donald Trump the same
DNC contractor also requested that
Ukraine's president publicly trashed
president Trump's then campaign manager
Paul Manafort and that's not all earlier
this month in a meeting with Ukraine's
new president a Democratic Senator Chris
Murphy he reportedly also threatened to
cut off you as Satan
that's what Trump didn't do that they
claimed he did and he did it if the
country opened an investigation into Joe
Biden and in a letter from senators Bob
Menendez dick Durbin Pat Leahy we got it
all all chronicled all the evidence you
need Democrats again threatening to
withhold aid if the government of
Ukraine stops investigating Trump Russia
collusion can you say quid pro quo I can
and that's where it happened with the
Democrats once again watching collusion
was Hillary the boomerang
once again oh yeah quid pro quo Biden
Menendez Leahy Durbin and Chris Murphy
take a look they got almost no attention
but in May CNN reported that senators
Robert Menendez Richard Durbin and
Patrick Leahy wrote a letter to
Ukraine's prosecutor general expressing
concern at the closing of four
investigations they said were critical
in the letter they implied that their
support for US assistance to Ukraine was
at stake and that every I didn't do the
right thing they wouldn't get any
assistance see doesn't that sound
familiar doesn't that sound familiar it
sure does
they're all guilty of that which they
accused president Trump of in this case
just like in the Russia collusion case
the only one paying for Russian lies and
disinformation impact the election in
2016 was Hillary it fits a pattern for
example remember when Obama
more flexibility over watermill more
flexibility after the election we got
the tape in case you forgot I don't
remember one Democrat calling for the
impeachment of oh don't tell the
American people we'll do it over the
election after that promise
what about collusion Democrats really
care about Russia collusion where was
the outrage we have the cowardly shift
the biggest liar in Congress we caught
him on tape he was trying to acquire net
naked pics of the drop naked pictures
well he was being pranked by people he
thought were connected to the Russians
yeah Russia collusion looking for dirt
on an opponent and we've got the tape
listen and she met with Trump and she
brought him one our Russian girl
celebrity Olga boo Sava who also known
as a person with a strange reputation Oh
boobs ever the nature of the compromise
well there were pictures of naked Trump
and was made aware of the availability
of the compromising material yes of
course thank you very much we will be
back in touch with you through our staff
to make arrangements to obtain these
materials for our committee and for the
FBI and I appreciate your reaching out
to us I got to admit I really loved that
what what is the nature of the
compromise can you give me the dirt
naked pics of the tombow yeah yeah oh
did flat Amir see them but the cause I
had to admit see the naked pics goes
much deeper than a man on tape colluding
with a Russian the Cowardly shift one
guy has been lying to us for three
straight years he just keep lying
biggest liar in Congress a cowardly
shift come on the program full hour
three hours of radio all yours you and
me mano a mano Democrats really
concerned about election interference
where is your fame phony outrage about
Hillary Clinton's dirty Russian dossier
or what the New York Times said late in
the game was likely Russian
disinformation from
the beginning if they cared about
obstruction where's the hysteria over
the thirty five thousand email
subpoenaed that were deleted acid-washed
and and little little phones hit with
hammers what happened to that if they
truly cared about allegations of sexual
misconduct and abuse you know the I
believer is demanding the Democratic
where are they demanding the Democratic
Lieutenant Governor resigned from office
oh they only do it when they can
bludgeoned Trump
where are the I believers with the
Democratic Party and Bill Clinton's
behavior and Juanita Broderick who
bravely came forward or Kathleen Willey
or Paul Jones though I believers then
and we can't forget about the big
elephant in the room which is sleepy
creepy crazy uncle Joe wants to be
President of the United States that's
not going to happen in fact if I make a
prediction tonight pay close attention
Joe Biden Joe 303 300 guests by
Elizabeth Warren in the primary because
what the Democrats are about to do is
throw him overboard because they know
that tape is damning his clear quid pro
quo and government abuse of power
surrounding Ukraine and China is going
to sink his campaign